-Now I thought I'd share some of
my favorite Thanksgiving fails
from you guys.
This first one
is from @msshawn80.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Shh! Shh!
You can't handle the tooth.
-It never happened.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @sarahbeezie.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, there you go.
Oh, a lot of blood
coming out of the turkey.
It's your hand, Uncle Bill!
-My fingers came off!
[ Laughter ]
-Cutting with the knife handle.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it falls
right off the bone.
Oh, my God.
Falls right off the bone.
Great job.
Moist bird this year, honey.
[ Laughter ]
Gross.
This one's from @Tinamarie0713.
She says...
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
This tastes like lavender!
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Imitates crunching ]
-It was nice kissing her
goodnight, though.
It was very lovely.
You smell great, yeah.
Very fresh.
-Your breath
smells like Nantucket Briar.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Nantucket Briar.
This one is from @IslaClifford1.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Yeah!
-[ Gruffly] Red potato.
-French-fried potaters.
Scalloped potaters.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Normally ] This next one's
from @inchilliwack.
He says...
Look at this photo.
Oops.
[ Laughter ]
That's what happens?
-Solid crust, yeah.
-I never knew what would happen
if I didn't use it.
Took it out of the pie pan.
-[ Laughs ]
I'm not gonna let this burn
in my [laughs].
-[ Laughs ]
-Don't wanna waste
this good aluminum foil.
-Oh, this one's good.
This one's from @lachute9.
She says...
-Aw!
-That's totally something --
[ Laughs ]
Just pour the whole thing.
-I strained it!
-This one's from @KelseyChole01.
She says...
Just look at the photo.
That's real.
She sent a photo right there.
Oh, my...
-Oh!
-Disaster.
I didn't even know you could...
-That's a fon--
That's a fon-don't.
-That's a fon-don't.
This last one
is from @ThisIsErikaC.
She says...
Oh, gross. There you go.
There you have it. Go to
"The Tonight Show" hashtags
to check out
more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.